في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه انها تمكنت من
تدمير خمس ناقلات جند مدرعه روسيه
وشاحنتين ومعدات ميدانيه اخرى على جبهه
القتال في زبروجيا ونشرت الوحدات الخاصه
مقطع فيديو وقالت انه الاشتعال النيران في
عدد من الاليات العسكريه الروسيه
والانفجارات الناجمه عن اشتعال الذخيره
الموجوده في داخلها كما قال الجيش
الاوكراني ان روسيا هاجمت الاراضي
الاوكرانيه باحدى وثلاثين طائره هجوميه من
نوع شاهد
اسكندر اضاف الجيش الاوكراني ان دفاعاته
تمكنت من اعتراض 30 هدفا جويا في المناطق
الجنوبيه والشرقيه للبلاد وقد اشتركت في
عمليه الاعتراض قوات الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات وطائرات المقاتله ووحدات الدفاع
الجويه المتنقله
قلى قائد القوات المشتركه الاوكرانيه
فانه يجري اتخاذ او يجرى اتخاذ التدابير
اللازمه من اجل رفع مستوى فعاليه نظام
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني وشدد على اهميه
حمايه المنشات الخاصه بالتدفئه ومرافق
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه مع اقتراب فصل
الشتاء
في منطقه العمليات الشماليه بالتعاون مع
رؤساء الادارات العسكريه الاقليميه يتم
اتخاذ التدابير لزياده عدد مجموعات النار
المتنقله وهذا ضروري من اجل زياده فعاليه
نظام الدفاع الجوي بحيث يشعر كل مواطن في
اوكرانيا بالحمايه ومرافق البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه للطاقه لدينا جاهزه للعمل في ظروف
الشتاء ونحن نتقدم بشكل كامل
الياس وفق هذه التصريحات نرصد معك تطورات
هذا الهجوم الذي تسميه اوكرانيا بالمضاد
في الجبهتين الجنوبيه والشرقيه
بالفعل والملاحظ في الساعات الثماني
والاربعين الماضيه هو ازدياد عدد
الاشتباكات المسلحه ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه على
محوريوجيا هذا ملاحظ مقارنه مع الايام
السابقه بان اعداد هذه الاشتباكات في
ازدياد مضطرد ومن ناحيه اخرى ايضا الهجمات
الصاروخيه والجويه التي تنفذها القوات
المسلحه الروسيه على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه في تلك المحاور القتاليه
ازدادت ايضا في الايام الماضيه على نحو
لافت وهذا يدلل بطبيعه الحال الى دراوه
القتال الجاري على محور زبروجيا في منطقه
بيرتفي
وكذلك زياده اعداد البلدات التي تتعرض
للقصف الجوي والمدفعي في تلك المنطقه من
جانب القوات الروسيه حيث قالت الاداره
العسكريه في اقليم زبروجي اين اثنتين
وعشرين بلده على الاقل القصف الجوي
والمدفعي الروسي في الايام الماضيه منها
اوريخوفكا
والعديد العديد من هذه البلدات التي اصبحت
ايضا بمثابه خطوط خلفيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
المتوغله والمتقدمه في هذا المحور
وبالتالي الطيران الحربي الروسي والمدفعيه
الروسيه تقوم بقصف هذه المواقع التي تشكل
الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات الاوكرانيه ومن
ناحيه اخرى نحن نرى بان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه تحاول ايضا فتح جبهات اخرى لصرف
الانظار ولصرف الجهد الحربي الاوكراني
المركز في محور زباروجيا حيث ان القوات
الاوكرانيه الروسيه فتحت هجوما عند نوفو
داريفيكا وهي منطقه تقع في الشريط الاوسط
لخط المواجهه الممتد من المناطق الغربيه
الجنوبيه للدومباس وحتى الزبالوجيا وعند
بلدات اخرى قري ايضا من الاقليمي الدنباس
وذلك في محاوله ربما لتخفيف الضغوط عليها
في جبهه زباروجي حيث يكثف الجيش الاوكراني
هجومه ويدفع بمزيد من التعزيزات هناك
ولجعله ايضا يدفع بتعزيزات الى المناطق
الاخرى للقتال من ناحيه اخرى
الوضع في الجهه الشرقيه
للجبهات القتال عند الدومباز معظم المناطق
تشهد مواقع دفاعيه بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه التي تقول بانها تصدها هجمات
للقوات الروسيه في مناطق مختلفه في اقليم
خركيف وفي دنيتك تحديدا في منطقه افديفيكا
وماريريكا وشختار حيث يحاول الجيش الروسي
احداث خرق في الدفاعات الاوكرانيه هناك
فيما يتواصل الهجوم كما يقول الجيش
الاوكراني باتجاه مدينه بخموت التي يسعى
الجيش الاوكراني الى تحريرها من ايدي
القوات الروسيه لكن من الواضح ايضا بحسب
بيانات الجيش الاوكراني بان ثمه محاولات
من جانب القوات الروسيه تحديدا عندك هذه
البلده التي حررها الجيش الاوكراني هنالك
محاولات من جانب القوات الروسيه لاعاده
السيطره على المواقع التي فقدتها في
الاسابيع الاخيره وكما يبدو بان معركه
كبيره جرت في منطقه السكه الحديديه
القريبه من هذه البلده حيث ان بعض المصادر
العسكريه الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن الكثير من
الجثث التي وجدت ملقاه في تلك المنطقه
شكرا جزيلا لك